[Música]
en mi casa las charlas sobre sexualidad
eran cotidianas y muy divertidas
mi mamá hablaba de sexo está en el
desayuno y solía decirnos que le tenían
realmente sin cuidado el horario de
llegada que lo mismo hacíamos de 9 a 11
que de 11 a 1 y también nos dejaba
quedarnos a dormir en nuestra casa con
el novio o el amor de turno porque es
una neurótica de la limpieza que
prefería eso a que nos fuéramos a meter
en quién sabe qué sábanas
mi papá por el otro lado que vivía lejos
pero tenía un lugar muy importante en mi
corazón
un hombre buscador espiritual me acercó
por primera vez a las filosofías
taoístas e hinduistas de ver el mundo
con un concepto de la sexualidad un poco
sacra y muy conservador
ninguna de estas dos visiones hicieron
que mis primeras experiencias sexuales
fueran realmente plenas entonces por
voluntad propia decidí empezar a
ingresar en el camino del taoísmo
dentado de la sexualidad con guía a mi
tía paterna hice todo lo que mi tía me
dijo compré los libros me aprendí las
respiraciones y fui muy juiciosa con la
práctica
pero cuando iban a la relación con el
otro seguía pasando lo mismo realmente
en mi si hubo transformaciones profundas
pero con el otro era como un vacío un
desasosiego
y queriendo buscar un poco más sobre
sexualidad en esta sociedad no sabiendo
en donde me doy cuenta que estamos
condenados a vivir una sexualidad pobre
y desinformada que hemos comprado el
concepto de sexualidad cómo se compra
una revista en un supermercado sin
ningún tipo de cuestionamientos ni
interés profundo
realmente parece que este tema ya está
todo dicho dicho por quien por nuestros
dos grandes maestros sociales el tabú y
la pornografía
hoy en día estoy absolutamente
convencida de que abrazar conocer y
apreciar la sexualidad hace parte de
nuestro florecimiento como seres humanos
somos seres sexuales por naturaleza
fuimos creados por la energía del placer
todos los que estamos aquí llegamos a
este mundo por un orgasmo así fuera solo
paternos pero orgasmo al fin de al cabo
como dice christine norte v en su libro
cuerpo de mujer y sabiduría la mujer
somos los únicos primates que no tenemos
nuestra libido ligada a nuestro ciclo
fértil y eso nos hace realmente unos
seres con un disfrute infinito somos
seres inherentes al placer
sin embargo la sexualidad se nos ha
convertido en una carga por un lado para
los hombres con un ideal impuesto a
superman en donde supuestamente su deseo
es infinito y claramente su elección
tiene que demostrarlo y por el otro lado
para las mujeres un lugar poco común
desconocido en donde hemos sido más bien
educadas para responder a ese deseo
infinito
en esta sociedad patriarcal el cuerpo de
la mujer ha sido por tradición
territorio del hombre del padre del
cónyuge del médico pero casi nunca
territorio de expresión de la mujer
misma existen falsas creencias de que
las mujeres no tenemos ni debemos tener
los deseos iguales a los de la masculina
nuestro cuerpo es valorado por un ideal
estético falso de belleza y es
considerada imperfecto por nuestra
naturaleza cíclica y menstrual
incorrecto generador de pecado según
fuentes religiosas es incompleto envidia
de pelé según freud
con este gran contexto social a pesar de
la apertura de mi madre y la visión
alternativa de mi padre puse un pie en
la sexualidad como lo hace cualquier
mujer en esta sociedad
entre al mundo sexual con una idea
absolutamente errada de placer
use mi sexualidad para conquistar a los
hombres
puse mi placer al servicio de lo
masculino pensando que hacer un buen
polvo era crear del coito un gran
performance en donde los hombres se
vieran obligados a quererme ya quedarse
a mi lado
así construí mis primeras relaciones
íntimas
tuve varias parejas sexuales relaciones
largas otras no tanto y fue infiel
varias veces y cuando miro atrás hoy me
doy cuenta que realmente lo que buscaba
no era alguien más o una experiencia más
lo que me buscaba era a mí mismo entraba
tan vacía cada relación sexual y salía
más desocupada habiendo entregado todo
lo que tenía y aún lo que no tenía
mi primera experiencia tántrico sin
saber en ese momento que lo era fue con
un hombre que por primera vez parecía
absolutamente interesado en mi placer
me preguntaba constantemente por mi voz
me lleno de caricias
y me doy cuenta por primera vez en mi
vida
lo importante que era que su meta
inmediata no fuera la penetración
también me doy cuenta que yo nunca me
había hecho esas preguntas a mí misma
nunca me había preguntado cómo me
gustaba que me tocaran como no qué
límites debía poner que debía decir me
había convertido en una experta
conocedora de los placeres masculinos
pensando hasta ese momento que mi placer
dependía de hacer disfrutar al otro
y entonces allí comprendí que no podemos
dar de lo que no tenemos
que cuando no estamos orgásmicas
extasiadas plenas con nosotras mismas
habiendo explorado nuestro cuerpo a
profundidad es muy difícil entrar en una
relación con el otro
por primera vez entendí que debía ir a
profundizar un poco más no en el otro en
mí
y es tan difícil conocerse en esta
sociedad en esta realidad que tenemos
porque ni siquiera tenemos a disposición
el conocimiento de lo más básico nuestro
cuerpo la anatomía sexual femenina es un
tema desinformado y desconocido en esta
sociedad las mujeres tenemos un órgano
que está en nuestro cuerpo sólo para
darnos placer no tiene ninguna otra
función el clítoris tiene 8000
terminaciones nerviosas que se conectan
con el tejido eréctil interno femenino
que estructural y funcionalmente
hablando tiene el mismo tamaño del pene
masculino
entonces si queremos nosotros también
tenemos pene y también tenemos selección
sólo que es interna
además de esto de este gran botón de
placer como lo han llamado algunos
expertos de la sexualidad también las
mujeres tenemos otros puntos que nos
hacen llegar al orgasmo según la
international society for sexual
medicine tenemos tres tipos de orgasmo
orgasmo clitoriano orgasmo vaginal y
orgasmo del cuello uterino
el estudio afirma que usamos diferentes
nervios para hacer la transmisión
sensorial que sube por la médula ósea y
llega al cerebro qué quiere decir esto
en cada tipo de orgasmo sentimos cosas
distintas no sentimos lo mismo
a pesar de esta buena noticia les tengo
una muy mala los estudios son muy
tristes esta entidad hace un estudio de
2300 mujeres en donde nos dicen que el
57 por ciento de estas mujeres ha
sentido alguna vez un orgasmo con otra
persona pero solamente el 3 por ciento
de este 57 ha sentido un orgasmo
diferente al clitoriano
yo no sé cuántos tipos de orgasmo pueden
haber esto es lo que dicen los estudios
para mí son infinitos yo he sentido un
orgasmo mirándome a los ojos con alguien
sincronizando mi respiración y
simplemente dejando que el placer se
expanda
pero si tenemos todas estas herramientas
fisiológicas anatómicas que nos
regalaban la naturaleza entonces porque
no disfrutamos tanto porque las mujeres
no nos sentimos plenas en la sexualidad
pueden existir muchas razones para mí
realmente tres básicas y estructurales
uno los tiempos dos el auto
desconocimiento tres la educación vamos
con el uno los tiempos
las mujeres necesitamos más o menos de
una hora a una hora y media para llegar
a los estadios más altos de la
sexualidad para que todas las hormonas
que tenemos dentro toquen sus picos más
altos y la irrigación sanguínea pélvica
llegue al éxtasis total
necesitamos tiempos largos saben cuánto
es el promedio mundial
5.3 minutos
en colombia tenemos suerte once minutos
lo que duran las propagandas del
noticiero de las 7
me encanta una metáfora que usan los
taoístas en este sentido
comparan la capacidad de respuesta
sexual del hombre con un fósforo que se
prende muy rápido pero se consume
rápidamente y la de las mujeres con un
gran cuenco de agua puesto al fuego que
cuando llega a la audición se demora
mucho tiempo en enfriarse pero también
se demoró mucho tiempo en calentarse
manta chilla en su libro el estado de la
sexualidad femenina afirma que los
tiempos largos y la des genitalizado de
la sexualidad no solamente es buena para
las mujeres sino también necesaria
porque cuando las mujeres entramos frías
al acto sexual y sobre todo a la
penetración podemos comprometer nuestros
órganos del aparato sexual reproductivo
y urogenital
vamos con el punto 2 el auto es
conocimiento
ha sido un tabú en esta sociedad hablar
de auto toque o autoexploración femenina
y hablo de esto y no de masturbación
porque la palabra etimológicamente
significa turbarse o violarse con la
mano así que prefiero autoexploración
hemos dejado esto para los hombres
pensamos que realmente son ellos los que
deben llegar a estos lugares de su
autoexploración porque su deseo es
infinito y volvemos a los tristes
estudios un portal británico experto en
sexualidad online rock doctor nos dice
que el 60 por ciento de las mujeres se
auto tocan el 80% de ellas usa juguetes
que simulan los penes masculinos lo
hacen en un promedio de 13 minutos y una
vez por semana comparado con 5 o 6 veces
por semana que lo hacen los hombres
y más o menos el tiempo que usan son de
5 a 6 minutos que nos dice este estudio
que las mujeres aún estando solas
volvemos a repetir patrones de sexos
rápidos y de fricción
tercer punto la educación las mujeres
hemos sido educadas con un concepto de
sexualidad que va dirigido a la
anticoncepción no quedes embarazada o
técnicas de detección del abuso es decir
hemos crecido con un concepto de la
sexualidad dirigido a la maternidad oa
la violencia pero quien nos enseñó a
disfrutar quién nos tomó de la mano en
este camino el disfrute del placer de la
delicia quien nos enseñó sobre los
orgasmos sobre la eyaculación femenina
que existe
porque el único lugar donde podemos ir
para consultar esos temas es a la
pornografía y ella no tiene idea de lo
que estamos hablando hoy y menos
tratándose de lo femenino
esta es pues una invitación para
recuperar la fuerza de voluntad de salir
de nuestra zona de confort es posible
indagar otros caminos está el tantra y
el taoísmo que nos dan una apertura en
el placer y lo ponen además en un camino
de conciencia
es posible tener la responsabilidad de
nuestro placer
tenemos derecho a hacerlo yo por ejemplo
nunca encontré el hombre del que hablan
los textos taoístas pero tuve tres hijos
con un hombre que se mostró
absolutamente interesado en explorar
conmigo mi sexualidad hasta lo más
profundo y hoy pensamos que esa
exploración es infinita
creo que nuestro cuerpo es nuestro
primer territorio habitado de derecho
tenemos derecho a ser plenas a sentir
todos los orgasmos para los que fuimos
diseñadas tenemos derecho a pedir
tenemos derecho a poner límites
definitivamente estoy convencida de que
el placer también es un derecho humano
[Aplausos]